كان الجسم يطير على ارتفاع
أربعين ألف قدم ويشكل
تهديدًا معقولاً لسلامة
الطيران المدني.
اتجاه رئيس
الولايات المتحدة للطائرات المقاتلة الموقعة إلى
القيادة الشمالية الأمريكية نجح في
إسقاط كائن محمول جواً على ارتفاع عالٍ على
الساحل الشمالي  من ألاسكا
[موسيقى]
نطلق على هذا الشيء شيئًا لأن هذا هو
أفضل وصف لدينا الآن ،
ولا نعرف من يملكه سواء كان
مملوكًا للدولة أو
مملوكًا للشركة أو مملوكًا للقطاع الخاص ، فنحن لا نزال لا
نزال  كان الجسم عبارة عن طائرة من طراز
F-22 تحلق من قاعدة مشتركة
Elmendorf في ألاسكا واستخدمت
هدفًا 9x لإنزال نعم ،
نتوقع أن تكون [الموسيقى] قادرة على استعادة الحطام
لأنها سقطت ليس فقط داخل
فضاءنا الإقليمي ولكن على ما نحن  نعتقد
أنه ماء متجمد ، لذلك
سيتم بذل جهود للتعافي
ونأمل أن تنجح ومن
ثم يمكننا معرفة المزيد
عنها